Hello everyone. How are you guys doing?
Hope you guys are having a wonderful
day. And today we are here with a video
on crystal keys. So basically, if you
guys are not aware, crystal keys are an
item within the game that are made by
half keys, a loop and a tooth half.
Those are mostly gotten into the game
through slayer jobs and random events
for the most part. And then from there,
basically what you do is you put the two
parts together and you run all the way
to Taverly. Now in Taverly, there is a
crystal chest that you can actually use.
It is located in this house right here
and you get a random amount of loot. And
basically what I'm here to do today is
kind of go through and see if it's
actually worth opening up these chests.
Now, right now I am on the old school
Runescape wiki as you guys can see. Got
a lot of information here. But
basically, they have an approximate
breakdown of everything. However, in the
past, I've noticed that this doesn't
seem to be right or I just got extremely
lucky in the past. Basically, some of
the most notable uh drops you can get
here that'll really up your loot value
are the runite bars, the iron ore, and
the rune plate leg/plate skirt. Now,
whenever you get those as drops,
typically you're going to actually make
a lot more money on each chest, as you
guys can see with the runite bars, the
ores, and the plate legs and plate
skirts. Now, if we look here, it says
the approximate chance is 1 in pretty
much 400, which would mean that if I
opened up 820 chests, as I plan to
today, I should only get two plate legs
or plate skirts. Now, from that, I've
noticed that that doesn't seem to be
anywhere near the rate. And basically,
as you guys can see, the possible loot
up here has been estimated off the fact
that these are actually right. And the
estimated loot per chest is 26,218.
Now, if that is true, I'm actually going
to come in at a loss. However, as you
guys can see over here, crystal keys are
approximately 27.1K to 27.3. However, I
bought all 820 of these for 26.6K.
So, that brings us up to a total of 21.8
mil for this entire video. And this will
be the testing I'll be working off of
today. So, we will do 820 chest. I'm
going to go ahead and show you guys what
a dry run of mine will look like. I'll
have another account there so that it
can pick up all of the runes cuz you do
get an annoying amount of runes here
whenever you get the rune table drop
because you end up getting 11 runes. So,
it's kind of annoying. But basically,
now I will go through and show you guys
what an average inventory looks like for
me. So, the first thing I would
recommend you do if you have not already
done this, go ahead and move your house
to Taverly cuz it's going to save you a
lot of time and I guess points. If
you're using nightmare zone redirection
tabs, you actually do have to spend
points per tab. So, if you just take
that 5 to 10k loss right off the bat and
just change your house portal, you're
going to end up saving more time and
money overall. All right, so this is
what the average trip is going to look
like. Uh, basically right here, 434K, I
guess you could say, but since I got
them all for 500 GP less than that, you
can subtract 8K. So, 426K is about what
you're looking at right here for the
average inventory. I am going to just go
and unlock all these chests so you guys
can see what I get from this inventory.
And then I will continue on with the
rest. So, if we go ahead and just do
this, basically, you get a guaranteed
dragon stone every time. And this is
what I'm saying. The coal right here,
coal is a 6% chance, and we already got
it right off the bat. But, let me go
ahead and drop these. That is the point
that I'm actually trying. That's the
problem with this though is that you do
get a lot of runes like that if you if
you don't have an alt account available.
Basically, what you're going to want to
do is just try and keep all of the good
runes that you guys can. And this is
what And this is what I was talking
about with the drop tables being a
little different than I actually think
that it says they are because in the
first inventory we have iron which is
supposed to be a 3% drop rate. We have
rune bars which are supposed to be a
3.5% drop rate. We have coal which is
supposed to be a 6% drop rate. And
really that that covers a lot of the
really good ones so far. We also have a
loop and a tooth half, both of which are
supposed to be 3% drop rates as well. So
that's why I'm kind of sketchy about
what the actual drop rates are, even
though they say that it's like lighter
than it is. I have, you know, reasons to
believe that that may not necessarily be
true. So let's go ahead and use all
these and then we will pick up all the
loot that we can see so far. So off the
first inventory, this is partially what
we will have. As you can see, 75k here.
Then if I switch over to the other
account where I have the majority of the
loot, as you guys can see in this price
check alone, it said, okay, we got to
take these out. In this price check, we
have around 400k, which means that since
we paid 426K, and you add on the 75K
that we have from the other one, that
pretty much means that we got about 470K
back from that inventory, and you know,
that's about a 50k profit, which isn't
too bad for being here only a minute. I
mean, really, in all reality, if you're
doing trips as quick as you can, this
shouldn't take that much time for each
chest. And now, I'm going to go ahead
and test the remaining 800 that we have
and see how long it takes me. So, I will
be back here in a second. All right, so
here's what the inventory will look
like. We have 14 keys. I'm going to
start up the timer now and let's get on
our way. I'll be back here in a little
bit. 800 keys later. That's the most
insane thing I've ever seen. I don't
know what the actual odds of these are,
but I got five rune bar drops in a row.
Like, I have to just go back just to
pick up the rune bars. Like, that's
ridiculous. And that's why I think it
may be a lot more profitable than people
think. As you guys can see, I got nine
rune bars over here, which is absolutely
insane. And I got two rune bar drops
before that. I can't even believe that.
That's ridiculous. And an hour later, we
have finally finished it all off. We
have all of the loot that we need. Yo,
large. Hey, what's going on, boy? All
right, but what we have to do now is
actually the hard part, and that is
finding out how much stuff we actually
have. And here we are trading over the
last little bit. As you guys can see,
uh, pretty much the only things I
collected on this account were just cash
decks, runes, uh, iron, and coal,
depending on the circumstances. Uh, and
that's about it. But there is a couple
things that I do want to touch on, and
that's what I didn't pick up. I didn't
pick up any uh, spinach rolls. I didn't
pick up any raw swordfish. On top of
that, I also missed out on what looks to
be about 14 rubies because, uh,
sometimes there's just a big stack and
you kind of lose track of some stuff.
So, as you guys can see, there's a big
disconnect between the amount of
diamonds and rubies I have. But with
that said, let's go ahead and check this
out. Now, one big big thing right here
is actually what the price of uncut
dragon stones is, cuz varying 700 GP is
going to skew this like 500k. So, I
think what I'm going to go ahead and do
real quick is go and buy one at the
Grand Exchange. I'll take out about 20k
that way I don't mess anything up. All
right. And so, an uncut dragon stone
right now is currently worth, let's find
it, 19.7K. So, not too bad at all. I
mean, we can just run with that price.
Now, if we go ahead and price check all
this, basically I will kind of do this a
little slow just because I want to see
uh what you can expect. So, the total
amount that we spent on all the keys in
total, as you guys can see right here,
is 21.8 mil. Now, if we go ahead and
subtract the 16.3 amount, which is
closer to what you can expect, this is
the amount loss purely based if you're
going off of just dragon stone. So
basically, so basically for each crystal
chest that you actually do, you're going
to be losing around 6.7K, which makes
sense. But basically with 6.7K, that
means that's what you have to average
back in all of this loot to actually be
able to, you know, overcome what you
were going to lose. Now, let's go ahead
and add some stuff nice and slow. So
coal, 1.5 mil, not too bad. Uh, diamonds
and rubies. I mean, they're worth
something. I was thinking about actually
putting these back into keys and using
them on the spot, but I figured it'd
probably be better just to have a
general example. And this is what I'm
talking about right here. This is
nowhere near what you would expect if it
was going off of what Wiki says. On top
of that, we have double the drop rate
pretty much of rune plate legs, which is
also a big thing. And way more of a drop
rate with coal and iron as you guys can
see. But if I go ahead and add
everything, I guess I'll just drop it
all in. We end up with 24 to 23.8 8 mil
somewhere in that range. Now, if you
take into account the fact that I
initially said that this cost me about
21.8 mil, that means that this is
absolutely insane as far as moneymaking
goes. I mean, I'm going to go and sell
off everything and actually give you
guys a accurate price as far as what you
guys can expect to see. All right, and
here we are. So, I'm not going to
actually quick sell all of these because
if I do that, I'm actually going to lose
a decent amount of money. However,
instead, I'm going to slow them. And as
you guys can see, we have 16.1 mil
there. And if you go ahead and add this
8 mil on, that brings us up to 24.2 mil
pretty much. And so there we go. I did
end up selling all of the dragon stones
off. That is absolutely insane. I mean,
just ridiculous profit to say that I
started with 21.8 mil and I ended with
24.2 means that I made 2.4 mil within an
hour's time. That's just insane. Um,
it's a chest that literally anyone can
access. The only starting requirement
that you need is just to have the money
to be able to buy these keys. Now, the
keys are I mean, you know, 26k per one.
So, to get 800 like I did, you're going
to need, you know, like 23 mil or so,
but it's definitely just an example of
the rich getting richer, you know. And I
know a lot of people may say that RNG
money-making methods aren't really that
good, and that's just not true depending
on what you're looking at. I mean, like
say for instance, if you're killing
something like shamans and you need that
one in 5k drop, even though personally I
still think it's good because, you know,
technically speaking, it still is. Um, a
lot of people may not like it because of
the RNG dependency. But here, you get
all of these drops like non-stop. Like
there's I mean, the only drop you don't
get that often is room plate legs, but
you get a room bar drop almost just as
easily, and it almost is the same price.
So, it's definitely a consistent
money-making method no matter how you go
about doing it. So, it's something I'd
recommend for you guys. If you guys want
to try it out, feel free. It's something
I always find to work. I mean, it almost
I've never tried it and been
disappointed. So, I mean, hopefully you
guys find this helpful. If you guys want
to see more videos like this, make sure
to leave a like if there's anything you
guys want to tell me. Comment that down
below. Subscribe to the channel if you
enjoy the content. Also, join the clan
chat. Large expand. Feel free to hit it
up, say hi to me, ask what's going on.
Feel free to meet the community. We got
Twitch and Twitter links in the
description as well. But with that said,
hopefully you guys have a wonderful day.